we're born into this world and everyone
jumps into this skin and thinks that
they're [ __ ] experts you know I mean
we've given no manual no nothing and
everyone straight away is a frigging
expert and that's a dangerous place to
be when you think that you know
everything that's a dangerous place to
be because like you said before I will I
will never stop learning
I will never fake perfection and I will
always want to be making mistakes I'm
joined by instructor from SAS who dares
wins and author of breakpoint and
battle-ready
Ali Allah ttan Ali welcome to the show
hello mate thanks for having me absolute
pleasure to have you on so first things
first the question that everyone has
come to find out who wins a hundred
meter race between you foxy and hunt
haha you know what well everyone would
expect me to say well I will win but I
wouldn't win that race because I am more
the endurance athlete as opposed to the
short you know short the lights of an
you know he's got a you know punchy
strengths and so is foxy so um but then
me and me and Billy amore they're sort
of endurance athletes so I will win that
got you okay well go for you can go for
longer but ant can maybe go a little bit
harder at a short pace I get it that's
totally fine so you run with my warm-up
act Chris Evans on virgin radio this
morning which is good yeah man I am
super super impressed with what already
I've got it last week and I've consumed
it in the space of six days and it is
phenomenal bro you should be really
really proud of it the bottom line is
you know it's feedback like that that
makes me proud of it because up until
someone else gives you I mean I got my
first testimonial yesterday and up until
that moment you don't know you know he's
because it's life experience you know is
it like you've got no measure or you've
got no until some actually tells you
what it's done for then you know it just
it's natural you
we all have that self Foster syndrome
comes in yeah yeah no exactly but um
yeah just just the feedback from people
is amazing and actually getting that
testimonial you saying that to meet you
right now is just phenomenal so I do
believe it is an amazing book because
it's it's not it's not a theory it's
life experience it's what I went through
it's the process I'm a living proof of
the the process that I've put in that
book you know everyone couldn't agree
Norman so why did you write it I wrote
it for that very reason I mean I went to
Thailand you know after the one of the
most phenomenal things I did in back in
2011 that there about was I went you
know I've spent my life bouncing all
over the world as a kid during the
Special Forces thinking this that would
be the be-all and end-all that would
tick every box I would be complete I
will be fulfilled and it wasn't it
wasn't and then I stumbled across
something that was happening in
Southeast Asia and it was working with
it with a group that we were busting
kids out of child prostitution and sex
slavery you know selling kids into sex
slavery and prostitution so we were
busting the kids out of that and putting
them back on track and giving them a you
know a proper they were having a proper
life where they were educated by
sponsors and everything else so what
that did no idea it would do that for me
that made me realize I felt fulfilled
absolutely humbled fulfilled and amazed
by that experience and that's when I
understood the power of helping other
people even when there's no real benefit
to me I mean I I was on I wasn't on a
wage doing that I self-funded the whole
operation and just that money can't ever
pay for what that gave me helping other
people and when you look at human
evolution the species evolving I think
we naturally meant to feel good when you
help someone else because we're giving
him a leg up you know I mean he's he's
enough we're meant to feel good about
that so that for me was the start
something that it wasn't
Tiffiny he changed my life it made me
understand the power of helping others
and now to be quite honest I mean my
whole business everything breakpoint and
everything we do is all based around
helping other people
I actually feel selfish that I can help
someone else you know when someone says
thank you to me I'm the one that should
be thanking you at a big 30,000 foot
view mmm how do you describe your career
up to Thailand for someone who doesn't
know who you are yeah okay well 18 years
old join the Royal Marines and had sort
of a I was disillusioned I got into the
military it wasn't exactly what I
thought again that was that was that
sort of typifies my whole military
career but then I was always chasing
something you know better it must be
better and that's why that's why I sort
of push myself towards Special Forces
doubted my ability to ever achieve it
but I did it and it was always some I
was always chasing that dream so
basically joined the Special Forces at
24 years old I was part of the SBS so
that's the special boat service so it's
like the SAS but we do everything
there's a lot of water involved and
stuff so and then again not fulfilled I
then left in 2000 I've always had this
desire to create my own business that's
always been my motivation so I kind of
did a few things but the trouble is you
know you so when you leave the military
there's such a massive void and you
really underestimate what you took for
granted you know the camaraderie and
everything so you can't you come out to
a massive void and then before you know
it the world that I said I'd never go
back into or go into swallowed me up and
that was as a contractor I found myself
out in Iraq 2003 to 2007 and probably
that was probably a lot you know quite a
horrendous time to crop it would be
quite honest it was a in a war zone for
that long it's not good for your mental
state so I kind of got
you know I was heavily other had a
lovely relationship with alcohol ended
up taking steroids at one point they all
would alpha male world and also I'd then
got hooked on valium you know it was a
mess it was an absolute mess but I was I
was functioning you know he it worked
you know I made it work I came away from
that you know my mental state wasn't
great and then I ended up you know again
I said I'm not you know I need to
redefine myself find something new get a
normal job and then realized pretty
shortly I couldn't do normal so and then
that's that's when I came across the
grey man which was the the the operation
to rescue kids from Thailand ended up
going over there doing that sunk all my
money into that I own sin Iraq and and
then that ended abruptly because of a
political situation which was horrendous
but one thing I took from that like I
said previously was the fact you know
helping others was something that really
meant something to me I felt fulfilled
and and then I came back again I was
actually really Australia at that point
back in 2000 sort of twelve and I
thought right you know I've been chased
out of Thailand you know it's a rest on
site we had to escape over the Burmese
border yeah it was pretty hairy and then
we got back to Australia I was like
right you need to grow up
you need to get yourself a real job so I
tried it again and I got a really good
job working in oil and gas but I was
like a caged animal you know and it was
like um what were you missing I was just
I was just missing that adventure the
adrenaline you know I was still at that
I was still you know when I look back
now I was I was quite a mess at that
stage and you know from and I know we're
gonna talk about this but um you know I
did remote from an incident that
happened in my childhood which sent me
on a path of absolute destruction
chasing mayhem and death all my life I
don't know how I've made it through but
I was still living that you know I was
still chasing this extremeness this this
it you know everything had to be an
extreme I was chasing danger
no consequence and no consequence no
yeah it was just it was a mess yeah I
was still in that world seeing even the
things that you did that were productive
and growth oriented I think was it
canoeing or rowing that you get to real
hard you're going to CrossFit super hard
you you've just chosen reckless
suffering even in areas that are like
growth you know you're like I'll just
bid myself in a CrossFit workout bid
myself on this Rowand yang I'll go all
over Australia up against some freaks
savages from the [ __ ] out back you
know rowing and rowing again so yeah you
can definitely see when reading the book
there is a unifying thread right between
everything it's always that that search
of of adventure of adrenaline of
suffering as well in a way that seems to
be quite cathartic to you that it's like
a release right so you've touched on it
there can you tell us this story from
the circus when you were seven years old
ten years old yeah it's actually yeah
ten years old ten years old it was a
bizarre experience but um yeah and a
life-changing one but this isn't burn on
Trent those that don't know burn on
Trent it's like right in the middle of
the UK you know it's like there's no you
know it's his land with land base you
know there's no see for miles around and
so it was a boiling hot day ten years
old someone came knocking on the door it
was my brothers it was my brother's best
mate and he came around asking if we
could ask Anne if we wanted to go
swimming mum was like yep can't wait to
get out out of her hair and and then we
set off and as we got down to the
swimming baths we actually saw that the
big top was setting up in town and we're
like wow the Chipperfield circus is in
town amazing so excited young boys we
like I walked in into a run and before
we knew it down at the big tops and saw
the first guy down there said look can
we have a look around
and he said yeah yeh said we're just
setting up there's animals out but they
won't change you'll be okay and and
that's that's it we went into the big
talk and I can remember I got separated
from my brother and his Mei and and
their I don't know what drew me towards
it but on the other side there was an
opening and
I was sort of drawn to that opening and
as I got to it the Sun hit me in the
eyes I couldn't see for a moment and
then as my vision cleared there it was
sat in front of me about 10 15 meters
away was something that just amazed me
and I was absolutely compelled to go
towards and that was a baby chimp and
before I knew it you know I walked over
cautiously and there it was you know for
me I bought up with with Tarzan Johnny
Wiseman black-and-white films you know
and for me that was a little piece of
Hollywood set right there
it was amazing and next thing I'm stood
over it ten years old and it looked up
at me with these beautiful eyes
and it was a moment we connected and it
sounds weird I know but we connected and
it was it was just surreal baby chimp
goes down picks up some food off the
floor starts passing it to me and I'm
like wow this is a this is a male I felt
like a miniature like David Attenborough
you know so a staff thought gee I'm not
eating that's disgusting so I was just
going through the motions throwing it
over my shoulder and it probably only
went on for 20-30 seconds but it seemed
like a lifetime you know I was brought
up with cats and dogs this was a chimp
you know middle in middle of the UK a
chimp and all of a sudden you know it's
a beautiful blue skies and the serenity
of that moment was cut like a fighter
jet racing through the sky as I heard
this roar and I'll never forget it I can
still hear the roar to this day heard
this roar and in the shadows under a
truck in the you know behind the chimp I
could see something moving and those
shadows that movement then became
clearly what was about a 50 killings are
though I don't know what size it was but
I didn't get a chance to weigh it but it
was bloody big and it was it was the
mother it was the mother you know is the
baby the the chimp mother which then Mac
10 started coming at me you know the old
sideways chimp movement yeah exactly
you know just raging absolutely raging
and I'm like a deer in the headlights
thinking oh my god and at the points I
thought you know this is the moment you
move you know this chimp just fired
straight up into the air I was watching
this thing's it was just rising higher
and higher in the air the blue sky
turned to black as this thing landed on
me and then started going to town on me
pinned me down to the floor I was pinned
to the floor and it was like a drummer
in a rock band
you know it's fists coming down onto me
as she was tearing chunks out of me and
it was just it was it was mental
absolutely mental I lay there and I just
remember thinking I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die unless I do something I'm
gonna die and it was in that moment that
I knew that I had to take a step into
that I had to take a step into further
discomfort for any chance of living that
day okay so I managed to sort of move my
body just a few inches and I dislodged
the chimp I managed to get my knee up to
my chest I kicked the chimp in the in
the chest and it just give me a couple
of feet just to get away and then this
chimp gets back to its free and he's
coming at me you know final attack now
it's got it's got blood dripping from
its teeth it was my blood and and then
it came at me and then a chain caught it
around the neck just before it got to me
and I was stood there you know ten year
old absolutely in a state of shock my
arm was like a you know a bone that had
been chewed by a dog or laughing he was
just a mess you know it's like he'd been
ripped apart there was blood all over me
and it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't a good
thing a good sight the whole place
erupted and and then they got me off to
hospital as quickly as possible where he
stitched me up and and that was that
really that was that was the the that
was the attack that happened at ten
years old you know and ya know it sounds
like something out of a movie may well
when I look back he you know he
sometimes it's hard for me to actually
understand it wasn't until recently and
I've talked about this in the book that
I opened up that chapter in my life
again but always
looking back up until that moment it was
like a movie in my head you know it was
yeah have you got any of them have you
got any scars from when it happened that
you can still see that visible yeah I
mean I've got my arm here which you
can't really see I mean that's the Scott
that's the big scar there I mean it's 10
it's healed up a lot but that there has
been this big chunk that's gone out of
that that there so I've lost no function
in my arm but um but yes I mean that
there's the scars really were the ones
you can't see you know and but you know
I always look back on that and I
understand now looking back there when
something happens like that in your life
you can just we naturally lock away the
intimate emotional detail we just do
that that's way wide but you you need to
address that and and and to think you
can have something like that happen to
you and that not affect your life
especially 10 years old is absolutely
it's naive well man scars are proof that
you're stronger than whatever tried to
kill you and that's that's truly both
true for both internal and external you
know well I mean I want to kind of jump
right ahead to where you are now and no
one's growth finished right you know
you're not a fully self actualized human
and you never will be you'll be growing
for the rest of your life but the
difference that you've made from the
dysfunctional way that you were moving
through the special service then when
you went into doing your more contract
work then in the tile and then being
lost and all this sort of stuff as you
say in the book this is a journey of
growth that you went through you've done
managed to restructure that into what is
what reads essentially is an instruction
manual and it's like a it's like an
activity book for adults that want to do
behavior change in personal growth which
i think is really cool so you've got
bunches of exercises in here all of them
ways that can serve you that can help
you to move yourself forward and things
like that but there's um before we get
into it do you know Jim Rendon's book
upside it's about posters I'll send you
a link to it once we're done okay and
this struck me straightaway
right so it's about the new science of
post-traumatic growth and he reports
that up to two-thirds of trauma
survivors experience post-traumatic
growth not post-traumatic stress they
are benefiting from the crisis in their
lives
by using them to become stronger Rendon
found that trauma can drive us to become
better to focus more on relationships
become more spiritual and become more
grateful and I've never seen more of a
perfect example of that than the
situation's you've been through yeah no
I think that's absolutely brilliant but
I think it takes a lot of time before I
think a lot of people with trauma
they're there they're still trying to be
the person they were before the trauma
and they're fighting to be and that's
where the conflict comes from you know
they're sure you're never going to be
that person again you a different person
so it's about you know and I talk about
this in a book it's about being able to
surrender to yourself to allow this
stuff to flow but the more you know he
said mines are a wonderful thing base
it's just the Pandora's box a confusion
unless you actually understand what's
going on in up on it on up here and
certainly that was that was going on for
me you know I'm I'm 49 years old now it
took me until I was 43 I was 43 when I
sort of did that boot camp I took all
that fine you know I not started living
properly until I was 43 absolutely not
life doesn't carry an instruction manual
you know like that there is no there's
no instruction manual that comes with
life and all of these approaches you
know all the people that I've spoken to
people that you've quoted in the book
people like James clear or Aubry Marcus
or at John Boyd you know that all of
these different guys that are masters of
behavior change they're just given us
tiny little glimpses into what we can be
and how we can operate and you know this
is why it is a never-ending quest but
which it which is both beautiful and and
unfortunate I suppose so
let's let's get into it there's four
main sections in the book right and the
first one is
what are some of the barriers re-what
it's the call to change so what is what
is the call to change yeah first of all
before you answer that I wanted I wanted
to just say that you know I think you
came up with a great analogy of the book
there but you know I've been talking
obviously a lot you know I've been in
radio been on you know quite a lot of
press around the book and stuff and do
you remember the Haynes manual that you
used to get for a car no right okay so
back in the day when you used to get a
car you used to get a Haynes manual and
the Haynes manual was basically for the
layman to understand the mechanics of
that vehicle it was for they it was it
allowed the owner to do a fault
diagnosis it allowed them to be able to
look at ways that they could fix the car
buy some extra parts even with little or
no experience it would tell you what you
needed to do to get the car working
properly and get it back on track and
make it the best version of itself
now that's what they used to do with
cars now I look at this book is exactly
that this is the Haynes manual for the
mind body and soul you know I mean and
you're so totally writing what you say
your thing is we're born into this world
and everyone jumps into this skin and
thinks that they're [ __ ] experts you
know I mean we're given no manual no
nothing and every one straightaway is a
frigging expert and that's a dangerous
place to be when you think that you know
everything that's the dangerous place to
be because like you said before I will I
will never stop learning
I will never fake perfection and I will
always want to be making mistakes I
think some people might think that
they're experts but far more people in
my experience just operate on their
programming and presume that it's okay
and you know it's it's okay in that
you're not going to get hit by [ __ ]
open traffic but yeah that's you know
that's the limit it's like you're just
existing the best that you can hope for
if you don't learn to deprogram all the
biases and all of the social constructs
and all of the things that the egos
giving you in all of the trauma that
you've got from back in your life even
if you don't think you've got any trauma
and all that sort of
the best that you can hope for without
deprogramming that is to become an
effective slave to the way that your
brain wants to operate and that is no
life that is no life and this is it this
is the beauty to me of personal
development and of behavior change and I
hate the fact that America's [ __ ]
self-help community wanky world has
bad-mouthed or has how would you say to
tarnish the image of one of what is
making people better you know and say
you've brushed across all of the big
concepts in this book so let's get into
them the cult change what is it your
call to change really you know and
throughout the book control I'm talking
through people through my personal
experience and what I actually did but
really the call to change is when we're
humans you know when things aren't going
right in our life when we've got that
internal conflict going on you know
we're not happy we want to be somewhere
else we sick of the same repeat repeat
habit loops we start comparing with
other people and that is a dangerous
place to be because you if you start
comparing to someone that is so far
above you are right you know their
vibration is so much different than
yours it's too hard a bridge to gap you
know you make it unrealistic and it
basically that just turns into jealousy
that turns into you know all the wrong
things so really what you need to do
straightaway is level with yourself
understand exactly who you are where you
are not compare yourself to other people
and that is the foundation for growth if
you're doing it because you want to be
like someone else you wanna you know
you're jealous that they've got a nice
house a nice car nice this and nice that
it's the wrong place the star so it's
really about understanding exactly where
you are and for me at that stage you
know the call to change was look mile I
am sick of this [ __ ] I am sick of
repeating the same cycles of life I'm
sick of wanting something and never
achieving it because I'm always falling
back into the same old habit loops
negativity that stands in our way and
enforces the the habit loop and it's
really it was just being honest with
myself it was being honest of where I am
and understanding that I needed to
change you know it's looking for me it
was looking at you know all the things
all the factors that are affecting me
and and like I keep I've been saying
repeatedly about this book at the moment
there was the there was the option to
pull the book at this time because of
because of isolation and we said well I
said the book was written in a period of
isolation you know and that's why I
think at the moment you know that's what
I had to do what I did I put myself into
a boot camp a mental boot camp I had
been strangely gifted a house by my mama
I had a spare house in the UK when I
came back to the UK and nothing else and
basically I was in I had such an animate
I was I was like a blank canvas and I
was sat there thinking at that time a
lot of people would have said that's a
[ __ ] situation to be in but I looked at
that as thinking wow how many people get
to do this I've got two months or
whatever it was to be able to just sit
there have no distractions and focus on
me serious well yeah when do you ever
get that opportunity right now right now
right now but you won't ever get this
opportunity again you know sitting there
thinking that the world's ending and all
that kind of stuff that's not serving
you what what you can control is
yourself and the people that sat there
all day long at the moment looking at
their phones checking Instagram or rego
gram I call it check-in that all day
long that is not gonna you're not going
to come out the back end of this as the
best version of yourself far from it so
basically that was that was it for me it
was about understanding where I need
change what I needed to focus on and
really just leveling with myself and
going through a process this was it for
me this and this is a theme throughout
the book forget what's going on here
when it comes to your emotions comes to
your feelings when you come up with an
idea that's from the frontal cortex you
need to think about that enough so it
loads into your subconscious but
basically it's that same frontal cortex
that comes up with a negativity when you
actually come to execute the ideas now
if I use running for example I want to
be a you know I want I want to I know
that running every day is gonna make me
fit in and next year I want to run the
London Marathon you're not going to feel
like doing that you're not gonna you
know you once you start thinking about
it your mind is wired to actually steer
away from any kind of stress any kind of
discomfort and people that wake up the
next going are you know I nearly started
but I just didn't feel motivated you're
not gonna feel motivated you have to
forget the emotion forget the feeling
and you have to execute a plan that is
based around a process so that really
for me that was understanding where I
was what I needed to do and point a
process that was void of feelings and
emotions and stick to it and remain
non-judgmental throughout and that was
really the start of it and that was
really the call to change identifying
the issues understanding what I needed
to do and lay out a plan of how that's
going to work I get it man
we do not rise to the level of our goals
we fall to the level of our systems yeah
sounds like the James clear ISM what
happened I just say something though hit
me mate
I absolutely on your Instagram today yes
the magic you're looking for is in the
work you're avoiding I love that shower
I've just taken that top off I'm just
taking that t-shirt off shout out built
up north for that t-shirt yet another
great one from them they also have
another one that says this is not the
[ __ ] cuddle Club so to CrossFit
CrossFit clothing company but yeah the
magic you are looking for is in the hard
work you were avoiding yeah what happens
if you don't choose a purpose for your
life what would we chosen for you you
know what people people understand that
people don't understand you know it's
like goals and purpose are very similar
you know your purposes is basically well
understanding your purpose is not your
goals actually your goals are on your
way to find your purpose but for me it's
you know when you understand your
purpose and people ask the question how
do you find your purpose now when you've
got a bit of experience a bit of age on
your side you can actually go back
through your life
and it's quite easy to identify at what
point you were happy what what made you
you know what was a happy part of your
life what made you happy
what made you fulfilled and that's
really what you should be doing moving
forward you know if there's something
you don't like doing then then try to
avoid doing it in the future if you're
young
you haven't got the benefit of that so
basically you really need to go out
there and start getting you know really
stepping into that short-term discomfort
to get as many experiences as you can to
understand what your purpose is so
really you know it's about understanding
it finding your purpose first of all and
then it's about having a having a system
of goals in place good not actually yeah
and basically it's it's having those but
if you don't people see itself that you
know in this self-development world and
people say who's who here's got goals
and you know you get some people yes I
are you know people that don't have
goals don't think they have they do have
goals regardless of whether you like it
or not ask a subconscious is a goal
driven goal getting machine and it will
focus on getting exactly what you focus
on what your dominant thoughts focus on
so if you haven't got a chosen goal it
will come up with something that you
think about you know that's your
dominant thoughts and nine times out of
ten with seventy thousand to a hundred
thoughts going around our head every day
you are going to end up with a load of
crap that you don't want very much based
on the facts as well all amplified by
the fact we are negatively geared and
I'm sort of jumping ahead because this
is the Mary hey I've got it talk to us
about the negativity default I've got it
that's the next that's my next question
are you reading my notes stop reading
myself we've got the same book yeah we
do that's exactly why yeah the
negativity default I absolutely layer so
tell it tells about that yeah it's
really for me in that boot camp I wanted
to understand it like a city and said
before about the Haynes manual I don't
you know a mechanic can't fix a
motorbike unless he understands how it
works what's going on and and basically
understand the workings of that machines
of that machine from then
can do a diagnostic then it can fix the
problem for me it was about
understanding what's why am I thinking
negatively how did I go from being a
special-forces hero to 0-2 app actually
sub-zero how did that happen and I
couldn't understand how that you know I
couldn't understand what happened
in-between and how I could fall down so
far and then I really you know I started
looking at the fad why do I think these
negative thoughts why do why does that
happen so I started to read a lot into
psychology but I really do think it
wasn't about reading it was about
learning to understand myself from what
was going on I really looked into the
back you know looked to sort of into
evolution of the species and and whether
you liked it or not our primal instincts
are the things that make us thrive today
so really you know you imagine a caveman
a caveman never came out of his cave and
went hmm right let's have a look
I wonder what amazing opportunities are
gonna come my way today
they were like where's that [ __ ]
saber-toothed tiger where's that monkey
but you know they were always looking
for what was going to go wrong because
that's the thing that kept them alive
until today we're still geared that way
everyone can relate to the fad whenever
something gets any kind of challenge
that they doubt they can you know it's
bit of a challenge they're always
looking for what could go wrong
it's just our natural default when it
comes to evolution of the species
there's no actual benefit to being
positive being positive and have a
positive mindset is not going to save
you from being eaten by a tiger so
really it's about understanding that our
system is based on negativity that's
just the way we are but once you learn
to appreciate that and not think that
you are just a singular person out there
that is subject to a negative mindset
and that guy over there who who seems to
win every day at work he is just gifted
there's a different person you're all
the same he just thinks differently
that's one of the key realizations I
think of overcoming a negativity default
it's to understand the the fact that you
catastrophize risk is not some personal
curse bestowed on just you it is an
in built fitness enhancing system that
our entire species has got because we
are not supposed to expend any more
calories than we need to because you
taking a risk might make you a bit more
alive but a lot more dead which is a
very bad situation to be in it's an
existential risk it means your genes
don't get passed on everything in our
evolutionary past up until 20 thousand
years ago benefited the people the
humans that were the most risk averse
and now because we've got for the first
time in history a surplus of resources
as opposed to a scarcity of resources
we're now just expecting our brains to
catch up and be like I don't need to be
scared of the cold shower I don't need
to be scared of the hi big roller
coaster thing it's like no no no all of
you [ __ ] ancestors did so you're
gonna be as well and yeah you know I I
think you're totally correct stepping
into the programming and you talk about
this in the meditation section as well
so I'm gonna jump ahead but there's a
concept called the mindfulness gap like
Laurie Allen and this is what you touch
on you give it a different name but just
giving yourself that second you know ii
think i just think actually is this
negative thought serving me is yeah is
this something worth being scared of
last night my dad me my dad having a bit
of a discussion he started his first
business and I'm like dad is this
actually something that you need to be
concerned about or is it just your
natural risk aversion manifesting itself
you know yeah
yeah no absolutely and a way around that
as well I was at I was I came up with it
a bit of a analogy if you call it that
the other day but when it comes to
something when it comes to what you when
you actually understand that that is our
default okay what you have to do when
you want to achieve anything in life you
have to understand and this goes back to
the imagine you're looking for is then
the work you're avoiding you know I mean
you are always going to stay away from
that short-term discomfort which will
then lead to long-term gain and that's
what a lot the book is really based
around I'm a previous book break point
in the whole ethos a break point is
around taking that short-term discomfort
but really what you have to have if you
want
start a business or if you want to start
anything like that you have to make sure
that your goal overwhelms your
circumstances if I can give you a bit of
an analogy on that if I said to you one
day I'm stood next to you it's freezing
cold
we stood next to a late there's pretty
much close to ice on the top and I said
mate
jump in there you'd be like exactly but
if I chuck the person that you loved
right in the middle of that and they
start to drown would you give a [ __ ]
about how cold it was yeah man I've got
I've got I've got a Liam I've got a
quote from the book here which is
talking about short cut syndrome and
this is one of my favourites favorite
bit so I'm gonna read you a passage here
so you're talking about why you hadn't
learned to surf even though it would be
cool to do you said my failure is linked
to my inability to see purpose in the
outcome of surfing yes I'm sure it would
be cool and very satisfying but until
you get the taste of success you fail to
see the need and purpose and purpose
alone is the one thing that drives
anyone to achieve their goals one day
I'll be able to surf as soon as it
ascends to the top of my goal setting
priorities
nailed it yeah absolutely absolutely but
the thing is my for all this time prior
to and the reason I've got a surf band
the reason I've got two surfboards in
the load of wetsuit is because my ego
wants to surf that's it you know you hit
the nail on the head when you say that
it needs to ascend to the top of your
purpose in life and yet this is quote
from Ray Dalio you can have anything you
want but not everything you want and
yeah choosing to do few things well
condenses down I think it is is another
part that I'm sure that you back you man
you're going to become a cool surfer at
some point but as I say not right now um
so you touched on it before can you just
explain the concept of a break point
please yeah a break point and and that
is really the yeah you know what that
that moment I got attacked by the chimp
was the reason I started my company
called break point but
that was the moment I was stuck
underneath the chin and it was the
moment I was going to die now at the
moment I could have laid down there and
just been torn to bits and not be here
today but I knew that I had to for any
chance of surviving that day I had to
step further into the discomfort of that
situation for any chance of long-term
gain and really that was my first
breakpoint it's the moment you decide
nothing's gonna stand between you and
your goals and you're prepared to take
that short-term discomfort because you
know there's a long term gain on the
other side of it saving their family
member that's drowning in the icy lake
exactly exactly exactly that point but
the thing is and that you know you don't
have to go to the circus and get
attacked after after watching this this
uh this podcast but what I'm saying is
that happens with everything in life you
know and that is why it relates to this
book being battle ready
it's about squaring everything away it's
about cleaning the dishes so it's not
there the next day for you
it's about take care of every little
thing stepping into that short-term
discomfort to make life better in the
long term and that's in every aspects of
your life it's making you battle ready
and that is the whole concept but that
is break point break point is the moment
don't you it's that sliding doors moment
of opportunity it's the moment that you
get up in the morning you know I put a
post on the small now don't know if you
saw it but it was in fact I don't want
it when when I wake up at 5:00 in the
morning I don't want to get up you know
after that I don't want to sit
downstairs and meditate you know I wanna
you know I prefer to just sit you know
have a coffee in a you know open my
phone up and just allow that negativity
and all that nonsense that ooze in from
from everyone else's lives and and etc
etc I don't want to then put my trainers
on and go outside I prefer to stay in
and just have a nice coffee and check my
email but the thing is I have to step
into that short-term discomfort because
I know the growth and the benefit and
the development are on the other side of
that short-term discomfort that is
breakpoint man can you explain what is
breathe calibrate deliver yeah
absolutely in breathe
calibrate deliver is something that you
know he's those have read it in the
other book and stuff he he you know I'm
related to respect my life in the
Special Forces but really it's it's not
just about the Special Forces although
they are teaching this method now in
some Special Forces units over the world
basically what happens when you get into
a stressful situation and take again you
know the late the freezing cold late as
soon as you fall into freezing cold
water what happens your breathing goes
mentally erratic doesn't it and the
first thing they say if you fall into a
freezing cold lake is you must control
your breathing and what happens at that
moment you know in any stress situation
your breathing becomes erratic and then
what happens cortisol increases and then
that's what leads to the confusion what
you will then do in that moment your
survival instinct fight or flight or
flight will basically say get out of
this situation as quickly as possible
and a lot of the time you're going to be
running straight into further danger
because you're confused so basically
what this what Breathe recalibrate
deliver is is in those moments as you're
moving into one of those stressful
situations take it for us stacking up on
a door about to go in you and the
Special Forces and anxiety on that door
is immense because you don't know what's
on the other side it could be a wall of
bullets it could be a bomb it could be
anything but you know there's going to
be it's going to kick off and and
basically it's about keeping that
cortisol level down you know if the
breathing box breathing so when I go
when I talk about Breathe recalibrate
deliver box but if you know in a stress
situation and try it when you you know
road rage or when you're having an
argument with you your partner or
whatever before you react breathe you
know and it doesn't have to be you know
sort of stand there and look but like
some Zen monk you know going into some
kind of you know it's just the fact just
breathe just take a breath first you
know breathe in for four seconds hold
for four out for four whole four that
will then lower the cortisol how many
rounds it depends on the situation but
if you've only got if you've only got a
short
telling to do so then basically I'd say
do it four times but if you haven't got
long just taking one breath and
maintaining that breathing through will
help straightaway as soon as you take
that first breath it will help straight
away it's just my new pause and at that
same time you caliber of recalibrating
recalibrating is like a triage of the
situation you're stripping away what
doesn't matter you get rid of the mind
chatter you get rid of the confusion and
then what once you've aligned with what
you need to do you then deliver the
action so you breathe recalibrate
deliver I love it I mean if it's good
enough for the SAS stacking up outside
of a room that's filled with potentially
a wall of bullets it's good enough for
you know Jonathan who's stuck in
rush-hour traffic late on the way to
work absolutely negotiation you know in
sales there's so many people have been
in sales you know you people sit in a
meeting and then they walk out the
meeting and they go oh my god I can't
believe I just [ __ ] said that and the
guys in the office go what a loser I've
just I've just won that deal and you've
you've actually you've done the opposite
of what you should do you've took the
shortcut and your minds gone get out get
out get out and if you have just not
allowed them to dictate and drop just
breathe clear the confusion and then
deliver an answer that's based on
clarity and not confusion you'll win 95%
of the time so what this looks like to
me is a micro version of what we've been
talking about in terms of deprogramming
right so you have this stasis that your
body is operating in over longer times
we call that nature but if you're in a
shorter time it's just the way that your
physiology responds and reacts to
situations and especially for the people
listening that are a little bit more
cerebral perhaps the people that are
introverts you'll think that you can
armchair philosophize your way out of a
situation you'll be able to seal try and
think I should think my way out of this
anxiety should think my way out of this
depression it's like there are certain
things and certain thinking tools that
you can use but the bottom line is that
if you got up and went for a 10-minute
walk did a little bit of breathing I had
a big glass of
water 80% of the problems in your life
would be fixed and I promise you that
it's a fact like a good night's sleep a
walk a glass of water and a little bit
of breathing will fix pretty much
anything yeah but the the opposite of
that is people tend to to not go for the
walk they had to open a bottle of wine
down that and then you know check the
phone scroll through the fan sit on the
couch eat some foods high in glucose
Iman it's you know if so many people
including yourself who's literally been
to the absolute elite of the armed
service in the world if you're saying I
think people should probably heed the
advice I got a question actually that
I've been wanting to ask you talk me
through your morning routine yeah
morning routine well I've taught you
through my morning routine today we
should pretty much the same as I did in
the boot camp it's the same I try I
don't do it every day I've got to say
that you know sometimes I've fought
enough I talked about that getting back
on track after you if you know you've
lost your way well I think what do you
think's your compliance with your
morning routine five in seven four in
seven
there's no set but I always look at the
8020 you know if I'm doing something
eighty eight percent of the time then it
then it's good but you know I'm not so
you know a lot of people actually
reading the book and stuff like that
must think God he must be boring too
liquid you know I I do you know I know
my faults and I know you know sometimes
up until about you know when I first
went to isolation I was letting that
slip I was eating really bad foods so
anyway morning routine for me now the
morning routine is so so important
because by me taking myself to the day I
dominate every time okay
or at least I'm in a good position to be
able to take anything that comes my way
now if you're the kind of person that
just you know is on the snooze button 24
so you know and and just gets up at the
last minute
you're basically allowing the day to
come to you and it's more while you're
gonna walk all over you so for me I wake
up now at five o'clock in the morning
that's just a regular pattern and I
straight away you know I know that if I
don't take action quickly my brain is
going to talk me out of it roll
overcoming my girlfriend and that's it
all over so it's really for me get outta
bed straight out bed I then go
downstairs and I meditate I sit there
I'll do a guided meditation something by
it I use a lot of Bob Proctor stuff I
don't if you you're aware of Bob's I
love Bob I think he's amazing but any
kind of meditation from me when I say
meditation you know a lot of people
think of they're too scared to venture
into it because they don't understand
what it's all about but for me it's my
focused attention at my intentions so I
use that time to sit there and it's it's
really about me being able to clear my
mind of anything else that's going on
and every time my focus gets distracted
you know I know how to get back and that
really helps me massively throughout the
day because prior to learning that and
it's the hard thing to do
I had mine chatter going on and it was
so you know just his mind chatter and
stuff and it was just so confusing so
that is 20 minutes in the morning for me
to be able to really focus on what I
want to achieve short-term in that day
in that week and you know and then my
big goals as well so that time as well
for me is about visualizing where I want
to be
I visualized like I've already been
there 20 minutes of that I then get up
I'll then either go for a run seven K's
which is from a house 7 K run and then
I've got the use of a very nice swim
pool at the moment so I then go for a
swim
I'll then I'll then later on in the day
go to the gym so really for me and also
I've done my fitness and everything this
is me time in my diary for the next year
I've put in my diary now up until 9:30
it's blocked out and that is me time no
one can penetrate that unless it's
something extremely important generally
up until 9:30 I am NOT available because
I'm working on me a lot of people say
look I'm got time to do all that this is
the best work you can do and that's on
yourself because the return on
investment will affect everything in
your life so that money routine for me
is so powerful and
one that's not doing it start doing it
because it changed your life man if you
win the morning you win the day there's
a good analogy here about when you are
in an aircraft with low pressure and
what happens in an aircraft is low
pressure is the oxygen masks come down
and the advice that you're given the
instruction that you're given is put
your mask on
before you try and assist anybody else
and the reason for that is if you are
suffocating you are not all that you can
be to help the people that are around
you and this is the basis of self care
if you are not making yourself
everything that you can be you're not
serving others in the way that you can -
and again Aubrey Marcus past modern
wisdom guests said you do not serve
others from your cup you serve others
from the saucer which overflows around
your cup and again if you don't think
that you have the time to work on
yourself you're probably the prime
candidate for someone who really needs
to consider it and get a copy of
battle-ready in' and go through
everything that's in there um so you
quote Joe Dispenza who's one of my
favorites and yeah brilliant start where
he says 80 to 90% of our thoughts are
the same as those that we had yesterday
how can people step in and break that
cycle process is absolutely processed
you've got to break that chain you've
got to break that habit loop and you've
got a pro set put a process into play
that takes you away from that repeat
cycle because again coming back to
evolution as far as our minds are
concerned we want to keep on doing what
we did yesterday and the day before and
the day before that because as far as
our minds are concerned when it's in
line with human evolution doing what we
did yesterday on the day before is kept
us alive until today he doesn't give a
[ __ ] if you're happy or sad whether it's
a good situation or not it just wants to
keep on doing that same thing when it
comes to evolution of the species it
will be so happy if you just sat in a
corner and procreated all day long and
didn't go anywhere because that's
dangerous you know that but then that
that's absolutely the whole thing about
this this conflict I talked about this
conflict this inner conflict there's
that you know that that's the driving
force for us to - for the
the evolution of the species but we're
there to create we're there to
understand we're there to to experience
and and really it's about if you want to
get out of that this you know all this
stuff all falls in line with breakpoint
it's the moat you've got to put a
process into play that breaks that loop
and understand as soon as you do it
you're not gonna feel like it but you've
got to step into the discomfort
initially because what's that what
that's doing is basically building a new
neural pathway in your mind you know the
negativity that the loop habit loop of
what you've been doing is like a
superhighway
and when you come up with something new
that is just that the neurons of a
firing but it's very weak but the more
you focus on the new habit those neurons
start to get and turn into a you know
like a country lane than a superhighway
and then the negativity will always be
there but the thing is you need to make
the positive or the new habit the new
superhighway of change and the only way
you can do that is by stepping into the
discomfort on a continuous basis day in
day out a lot of people say all you know
I have to stop doing that because there
are so many obstacles in the way the
obstacles are the way um so we've spoken
about the fact that we have a call to
change we've spoken about some of the
barriers the way that you need to
sustain change by having a process in
place you need to connect to a higher
purpose you need to actually be able to
understand what's going on so that you
can see the thoughts in your mind for
what they are but then we need to
sustain that right we need to keep that
going and one of the things you've just
touched on it there people come up
against failure they remind a
challenging time they come up against
failure they run out of motivation so
how can we ensure that the good habits
that we've put in place we don't you
know run out of motivation we don't feel
like we're a failure
yeah there's a lot of things there but
you know I said I think I said it at the
start of this Kristin he was like you
know I'm sick of people faking
perfection you know you
got to understand that I mean I
personally if I'm not making mistakes I
know now that I'm not trying hard enough
my goals aren't big enough for I'm not
trying hard enough and I understand that
your way to success is is is is a series
of failures you know but those for me
just reframe them they're milestones of
growth they're only failures if they
knock you back and you're too scared to
go forward again it's like a pinball
going up you know you want the pinball
to go straight up the center but it
doesn't it gets not from side to side
and sometimes it even gets dropped all
the way back even with the flippers you
can't bang it straight back up it goes
straight down again but you've got to
understand that on the way to your goal
you're gonna get not to the left not to
the right but you've got you've got to
have a goal on the other side that's
pulling you through but you've got to
understand that you know those failures
are gonna reshape the way that you
approach your goal and even when you get
to your goal forget the goal you're not
supposed you're not supposed to be
satisfied when you get to the goal and
even if you don't make the goal use 75%
in it's a it's a it's a long way better
than 0% in you were you know sometime
before so really for me it's about
understanding that yet keep on failing
keep on failing I mean the quote at the
start of the book is about no goal was
ever great and unless at some point you
doubted your ability to achieve it you
know and it's all about you know it's
all about having goals you know it's so
important to make sure that you choose
it define goal that you want that
challenges you you know that it can be
broke down to bite-sized chunks that you
you tackle each one of those bite-sized
chunks you know each one's a milestone
you get to that that gives you a
confidence to keep on going you but
you've got a really cool exerciser to
the clock the clock yeah right and as I
was as I was reading I made a little
note on the side any large goal is
achievable given enough time and small
enough steps that's it yeah you know
there is there is literally if you if I
give you an infinite amount of time
there's pretty much nothing that you
can't achieve you could walk to [ __ ]
Mars
you know like given enough time and
small enough steps you can
achieve literally anything and I like
the idea that you break down a large
grand goal this is very imposing this is
very challenging I don't know how I'm
gonna do it and you go okay what's the
next action well it's a very very very
next thing and this is how it links into
the morning routine right you're like
look I need to do all this [ __ ] today
but first I need to pull the covers off
me yeah
then I need to get out of bed then I
need to brush my teeth then I need to do
the thing like that's it it is all that
life is is a series of actions that lead
to accomplishments overtime and anything
great any great sportsman or speaker or
artist anyone who's gonna tell you the
same thing and you look at a piece of
great piece of art you don't see
individual brushstrokes but by
definition that's precisely how that bit
of art was made right exactly exactly
and that's that that exercise in the
book I think it's such a powerful
exercise and I actually did that my life
was absolutely a robot rock bottom at
that point so I basically you know I had
a drew round a CD I put clock hands
through it or knock clock hands just
lines through it like you know a 12 or 3
a 6 and a 9 and you know at 12 o'clock
was my main goal what do I want to
achieve and each one of you know some
people might not have to do all the
hands of the clock you know they might
don't only have to do 6 and 9 but
basically I went from 12 and then at 3 I
put what I needed to do we're on it
where my first goal was and and and and
hands 1 and 2 with the steps I needed to
take to get to 3 and then you just keep
on going on and on and on but the thing
is all the way along you know you have
the goal you plant the goal into your
subconscious once it's you keep thinking
about and that's why I use the morning
routine to think about that I'm putting
it into the subconscious because it ties
when times get tough you need to forget
the goal especially if it is an
audacious goal which it always should
scare the [ __ ] out of you and basically
you know if you focus on that goal if it
is a scary goal when when times are
tough your mind will just fall apart
you'll be like that's too tough but the
thing is that's when you need to get
your head down and just keep on moving
we we call it in the Special Forces one
meter square you need to keep them
and just allow just concentrate and
what's on that meter square don't go
don't go don't freeze don't go static
but just keep on moving towards the next
goal I climb Mont Blanc last year you
know and I'm always thinking of you know
I think that was that was powerful for
me because you know we were walking up
and it was like I kept looking for and I
was like getting so demoralized because
it just didn't seem to do getting any
closer and close for the top of that
mountain and I was like you know just
forget don't stop looking up there you
know just stop looking up there look at
your feet and just allow your feet to
keep on moving and then every time we
stopped for a breather I didn't look up
I turned around and I looked how far we
come on wow what a [ __ ] amazing view
and that filled me with absolute power
and then it was turnaround crack on
again but you know it's and that's
really analogy for how you should
approach your goal do you think it's
surprising for people to hear someone
who from the outside looks like a very
classic Hardman driven you know the the
signature Action Man Special Forces this
guy's got an iron will and [ __ ] balls
of steel and a jaw made of granite and
all this [ __ ] you know like do you
think it's strange for people to maybe
hear this side all of the self-doubt all
of the worry all the concern all of the
trauma that's been brought through yeah
I through a hundred percent but that's
what I feel it's so powerful for me to
be actually level with people and tell
them the truth because people you know I
remember someone saying to his rude you
know not too long ago saying wow you
guys to cut from a different cloth and
that's her mattering I said no we're not
I said we're just the same as you we're
just the ordinary people doing
extraordinary things and really it's so
important for me in this book and my
previous book to be absolutely 100% open
and let people understand that we're
just the same as everyone else you know
and that really helps people so that
really inspires people and that is you
know at the end of the day my books I
don't care honestly you know they
obviously pay a dividend but the power
for each of my books is what it gives
other people and I can't do that if I'm
faking perfection that's great so I've
got one final quest
which is what would you say to someone
who is in the same place that you were
in seven years ago lost in life
potentially with a sense of
meaninglessness pointlessness addicted
to some sort of drug or dependent on
some bad relationship feeling like
they've got no future nowhere to go no
way to grow what would you say to
someone that was you seven years ago
yeah well basically I would I would I
would tell them that they need to
understand that what they're looking for
is not out there it's not external you
can you know I was bouncing all over the
world trying to find something that
wasn't there you know the magic and
everyone everyone has the magic but it's
within you and the as soon as you start
to look within for the answers you will
be given the answers okay so it's really
about slowing down and for me you know
it's so important a lot you know it's
hard to come across in the book as if
you know I'm some raging alcoholic it
wasn't the case you know for me I
understood how put through my life
experiences that had been some crazy
ones I understood how powerful the mind
is so for me to add a chemical to that
and disrupt that clarity and disrupt
that power was absolute madness it was
like putting diesel in a petrol car
but for me it's about getting rid of all
those external factors that are cannot
benefiting your productivity get rid of
the alcohol get rid of the drugs and
especially if you've suffered mental
health issues PTSD whatever it is unless
you cut away the smokescreen you're
never going to get to the raw nerve so
it's about making yourself as healthy as
clean as much clarity as possible drop
down get to a level playing field of
absolutely where you are create a
foundation of growth not not on a
comparison of someone else and really
start to put a plan into play that has a
goal that takes you out of being a
victim of circumstance
dude Olli you killed it man we made it
we made it Frank's right I am I have
to say man I've said it before we got
started this book's fantastic this I'm
gonna keep an another copy I'm gonna buy
for my dad so dad if you're listening
you're gonna have one of these landing
in the house pretty soon and I'm gonna
make him go through it I think it's a
fantastic overview of behavior change I
think you've got a really good process
in there and some of the stories man
like some of this stuff you trip we
didn't even get on you trip you did
ayahuasca you went all the way out to
see some sharma and all this mad stuff's
going on so yeah I am
I think I think it's phenomenal really
really hope that it changes a lot of
people's a lot of people's ways that
they operate and their lives for the
better as well so where why should
people head they want to find out more
about you more about the book where do
they go yeah I've actually got a website
I mean I think it's a lot easier that
people go to my website which is a Leo
Double L IE o Double L e rton Co UK olio
listen Co UK it's got all my projects
all my books everything on there you can
find me on Twitter social media
everything and may please if you want
those books for you dad what everyone
needs to make sure the sign for you with
a nice message so please tap me up there
that would be fantastic and I will repay
the favor mate if you're ever in
Newcastle get yourself a peer and will
go on my Jim I will get a good CrossFit
workout another absolutely mate love it
thanks three time I really enjoyed it
and you man
[Music]
you